[Music]
we entered a previous video by writing
this number with the help of commas like
this using comma clearly makes it easier
to express the number in words it's for
cross 23 lakhs forty-nine thousand eight
hundred and sixteen but hold on why have
you used the commas in such a way we
left three digits from the right then
two then two again well that's the
Indian system of numeration commas are
used to mark thousands lakhs and crores
so I add a comma after three digits
leave two more digits and then marked
another comma and then another comma
after two more digits remember will
never be a marking commas we go from
right to left always it tells us that
the number is 4 cross 23 lakhs 49
thousand eight hundred and sixteen
that's how the Indian system of
numeration works leaves three digits
from the right then two digits and then
two digits again three to two and so on
thousands lakhs and crores
now I will give you two numbers and
using the Indian system of numeration I
want you to mark commas and also write
the numbers in words here are your
numbers now let's form a table like this
we have the numbers in the first column
and we have two more columns for you to
write the numbers using commas and then
inverse let me help you with the first
one let's just copy the number without
the commas in the second column first
first comma three digits from the right
then two digits and then two digits
again this is how the number will look
with commas and this will easily help us
to write the number in words it will be
eight cross 75 lakh sixty-three thousand
two hundred and one now using the same
concept I want you to fill these two
cells of the table and this is what you
should get
so I hope the Indian system of
numeration is clear now go left words 3
2 & 2 thousands lakhs and crores now I
want you to imagine this situation say
you travel to the United States of
America and end up talking to a couple
of people from there and you tell them
that the population of India is 130
crores well guess what they will have no
idea what you're talking about it's
because they don't follow the Indian
system of numeration they use the
international system of numeration now
the international system is interesting
and quite easy to understand why do I
say it's easy here's why in the
international system this is 1000 this
is 1 million this is 1 billion and this
is 1 trillion 3 zeroes is thousand six
zeroes is million nine zeroes is billion
and 12 zeroes is trillion multiples of 3
is a good way to remember the
international system there's no concept
of lakhs and crores in the international
system if you look at the last number
notice how the commas are marked 3 3 3 a
comma is marked after every three digits
from the right like the Indian system
talks in terms of thousands lakhs and
crores the international system talks in
terms of thousands millions and billions
the best way to understand both systems
is by comparing them
I'll give you a few numbers and together
we will try writing them in both systems
here's the first number it's 1,000 and
it's written in the same way in both the
systems Indian as well as international
both systems start off with thousands in
the Indian system it's thousands lakhs
and crores and in the international
system it's thousands millions and
billions here's your next number in the
Indian system we mark one comma three
digits from the right and then one more
after two digits this one gives us 1
lakh what about this number in the
International System in this system it's
just 3 3 & 3 from the right so we mark 1
comma 3 digits from the right and then
we stop as there are only three digits
left we can't really mark a comma here
can we
so one lakh in the International System
is nothing but 100 thousand now can you
write the following numbers in both the
systems here are the results the third
number is 10 lakhs in the Indian system
and 1 million in the International
System what about the fourth number in
the Indian system it's 1 crore can you
tell me what's it called in the
international system yes 10 million can
you tell me what these two numbers will
be called yes 100 crores in the Indian
system and 1 billion in the
international system
now try writing these two numbers in
both the systems using commas as well as
words and tell us your answers in the
comment section below
[Music]
you